[Music]
Google is finally getting serious about
self-driving cards as in it's getting
serious about making self-driving cars
and putting them in consumer hands now
the tech giant is finally making its own
self-driving car company called lame-o
in the seven years of the original
experimental phase Google has put more
than a few notches and it's felt after
more than two million miles of driving
its cars can dodge jaywalkers and
interpret hand signals from construction
workers they've mastered the dance of
the four-way stop they pull over for
emergency vehicles and they brake for
squirrels to prove it's ready Google's
car carried a passenger around public
roads with nobody around to take control
in case something went wrong we drove
all over the Bay Area and showed that
yes indeed we had the capability this
trip was about showing that we can
actually take that capability and turn
it into something that's ready to go out
into the real world Oh in that passenger
he's legally blind the drive was a quick
10 minute or so loop around the Texas
Capitol which conveniently doesn't have
any laws saying you have to have a human
back up for a self-driving car but for
Steve Mahan it was a really big deal
going where I need to go in a vehicle
without having to make arrangements with
other drivers or a family member or some
form of public transportation it just
let me be a whole person again
ever since deciding to make a fully
driverless car one without a steering
wheel or pedals google has harped on the
potential to put anybody who can't drive
back in command of a vehicle and now
that Google's finally talking about
bringing that technology to market a
fresh litany of challenges arises to hit
the ground in cities around the world
way mo must map every inch of every
Street it's going to travel it has to
drive down hardware costs and prove its
software to the public and to public
officials it has to navigate a spaghetti
bowl of regulations that change from
city to state to country a lot of which
haven't even been written yet it has to
figure out how to manufacture cars and
then squeeze money out of a newborn
industry that's already crowded but if
they can figure it out they'll have at
least one customer ready to hop aboard
I am piling up a list of all the places
I need to go